yes in daniel's kind of play it's i
think david kind of said it he has too
much respect for these worlds greats and
uh what oh wow
the players are spoiling us today
because now daniel is actually playing
my favorite opening the cara and just
like that
just like that it gets even better
because we have one of the sharpest
lines in the advanced karakan when white
commits the pawn structure by pushing
the pawn one square to the e5
this is the advanced variation and uh
he's chosen one of the most aggressive
replies which is just immediately
challenged in the stanza by pushing the
c pawn forward um but right now okay he
plays this move instantly oh okay not
hanging around he wait uh he plays it
but it isn't attacking anything so he
plays it first similar idea he's trying
to tie down this black bishop but while
the white queen has jumped out it will
invite attacks against it so one will go
down to like time scramble or you know
yeah okay enough time on the clock so
you need to be attacking you need to go
for the king you need to end the game
before you run out of time and
naraditsuki just spending a bit of time
thinking there okay knight takes porn
it's okay it's been played before it is
very frustrating because like you're
completely overwhelming clear cut way to
do that okay he does bring his night out
sensible white immediately castles and
when the queen came out i was like no
you push you you kind of kick the queen
away it's a bit annoying because of the
king's safety and the because it's not
very easy to unravel on that side of the
board small factors adding up means that
black's position is going to be hard to
handle he does actually spend time
in the meantime white will just keep
gaining momentum
comes with a threat exactly and now
naraditsky has to do something with his
queen obviously
and uh what would you do block
yeah probably block because it's not
clear whether black queen wanted to go
wherever she goes she'll probably get
kicked around anyway because now after a
trade we would see
this night under a fire the white queen
could just take this knight for free and
actually this black knight has to go
back to a terrible square and later on
why can even just take it and ruin the
black pawn structure if he wants you
don't want to put her on the edge of the
board and okay and daraditsky doesn't go
for that instead he brings his queen out
and this makes some sense too the queen
was uncomfortable on this square but
he's taking liberties the black king's
still caught in no man's land it doesn't
quite work but here i kind of want to go
okay
bishop i actually wanted to carry on
attacking the queen okay so you could
bring the bishop out for example and
start attacking some stuff exactly um
this wasn't played magnus just keeping
things simple for now that's nice i like
it
easy is good easy is good and yeah if we
count how many pieces are developed
white here he has some fantastically uh
active pieces all on great squares all
and pretty much their optimal squares
black meanwhile not castled his king yet
and okay he's trying at least next move
black is finally gonna try and castle
his king when it finally does commit and
we do see that move the white knight
trying to eliminate its counterpart on
the show remember that as well
yeah yeah
okay meanwhile we did see one of the
moves we predicted the pawn step forward
attacking the white queen and that's
good and now would you play knight takes
night okay it's on the board and after
rook takes knight okay so now the big
issue is you know i'm just looking at
that light square bishop it's a little
bit loose for my liking once you
mentioned earlier maybe bring the bishop
to the side yeah
bring the bishop this way so black
didn't go for that one he did get his
bishop out of the way and now i expect
magnus to just play a very simple
developing move maybe you can still
think about this but it's a bit flashy
there's no need so magnus does indeed
just develop his bishop and look at this
it's on the same diagonal black actually
had to take a time out he had to in this
position step forward with his pawn
stopping white from ever pushing his
pawn forward i could even imagine a
situation where you even plan to rook
into this square and you kind of pin and
win later on you this night now the
black knight is doomed on this diagonal
okay he's castled now
wow queen takes knight then you can just
add some extra attackers it's on the
board david queen takes porn and here
we're going to see it queen takes porn
played by nareditsky
i think he's just checkmating i think
he's going to win push your pawn forward
because
any illusion okay he's on the board this
would lead to checkmate um this
checkmate uh i mean it's very simple
it's kind of one of the first checkmates
we learn in the game the kiss of death
the king trapped in the corner and uh if
this happens this is the current
position if this happens if black takes
this knight i think he's just doomed
porn and then kind of intercepts
okay
wow naradiski he's really
really asking magnus
go on then even if he takes a time out
magnus there's going to be threats
against the black king and he does lose
his bishop so now the threat is actually
to play rook takes pawn
and uh
he defends with his bishop i thought he
might defend with his king naradiski
resourceful stuff but magnus
david putting the boot in he's going in
for the attack with his knight that's
actually a sacrifice
that's in the style of mikhail former
world champion just giving up his pieces
he's hoping that after that knight is
captured pretty much has to be captured
um then suddenly the white bishop will
recapture and the diagonal is opening up
towards the black king white's light
square bishop is suddenly going to
become a potent attacking force um so
that's at least four or five attacking
pieces black is not defending with
enough you can just drop back with your
queen
on the board david it's on the board in
order to win but in the current position
actually this is going to happen the
king has moved queen has dropped back
queen has dropped back in this position
now can i actually see other scenarios
where okay so the rook moves and now the
bishop can actually move to the g5
square and it says 100 on the bar okay
it's on the board david and naraditsky
did you see that he applauded
that's the streamer that's the streamer
he's also a streamer because he lets the
checkmate happen on the board no
resignation he shows the fans why the
game ends and that's checkmate
wow
well uh magnus carlsen was checkmated
against deliverance of russia but he
checkmates uh daniel naraditsky in the
next game a win for